what has it been like to sort of reach
this new level
of stardom and what's been i guess the
best part and what's been the hardest
part for you
i think the best part has just been the
people that i've met and the connections
i've made the friendships that i have
now and like are continuing to
get are like such deep and fun
and loving relationships i think the
hardest part
would probably be like just i guess the
negativity
i feel like that's a pretty common
answer but i think just dealing with you
know
the fact that there are just going to be
people that don't like you and
will always have something negative to
say about you and i think a big part of
that too was just kind of dealing with
like
the pressures of being so talked about
on the internet
at a time because it's like that's when
the negativity is the strongest
and it's like body image and you know
just things like that were really hard
for me to handle at first because i
wasn't used to that and it's like
now um i like noticed myself
getting like super hard on myself about
it and like letting that get to me and
it's kind of just um a part of growing
through it and just being like
look this is who i am this is who i was
meant to be and i can't let people that
don't truly know
the real me in my heart you know and
haven't met me
kind of determine how i feel about
myself so that's been the hardest part
but
there's so many good parts about this
industry and the social media world that
like
it kind of just outweighs it speaking of
the negative comments i love that you
sort of put this body shamer in her
place
i just feel like everyone needs to know
that like bullying
and body shaming is not acceptable and
not
okay mom for you what was it like to see
her getting that negative
commentary on her post and was there
like a conversation that you guys had
about that i feel like this is a good
learning experience for other young
girls out there
no for sure yeah it's definitely hard
for a mom to see
those things and try to explain to her
a lot of people are struggling
themselves with with issues
and to not take those things
and hold them in to talk about them
to get it out like if something is
bothering her and
she's struggling with the negative
comments also try not to listen to them
try to let it go after you've talked
about it
just let it go and don't hold it to
these people
they're they're behind a computer screen
they're we don't know what they're going
through
themselves yeah and i think for me too
that's what i've told myself forever is
just like
like my entire life of course has always
been negativity no matter what and like
you always
go through something that you know
someone just doesn't like and i think
i've always told myself
those people could also be going through
things and sometimes when
you know you're going through a really
hard time you feel alone
and you kind of want someone to feel
that too and you're like you know as
much as it it
it hurts and like you want to just let
someone feel it too because of how bad
it hurts and you want to be able to
get some of the pain off of yourself
it's just at the end of the day it's
such like a baggage to carry and i think
that
my advice for anyone out there that is
getting body shamed or going through
negative comments and stuff is just that
you know other people are going through
things and and you can't let that affect
you because you're beautiful you're
perfect and the way you are is
exactly how you're supposed to be and i
think at the end of the day every
imperfection you have makes you
completely unique
and it's something to really embrace and
just be like you know this is me this is
who i am
this is what makes me stand out and
different and then to the people that
that are the ones maybe putting the
negativity in the world i think it's
just
there are people that love you and that
are willing to talk to you and
and make your life better in any way
they can so always be open to talking to
someone and
if you can't trust you know a friend or
a family member there are plenty of
people that would be willing to
help you out and you are loved and
that's what i have to say about that